you share that view of the of the
majority so I'm going to stand in the
the middle here and introduce the teams
and the way this is going to work is
each team will put their first speaker
forward who will have four minutes to
either oppose or propose the motion that
the other side will get four minutes
then the other speaker in each team will
have four minutes the two teams will
then have three minutes to respond to
what the other size of just said I'll
then throw it open to you in the
audience for some questions at specific
panelists or both Pat both set both
teams and then each team will have three
minutes to sum up at the end the motion
today and I'm going to ask for a show of
hands on this before we start so the
winning team will be the team that moves
the center of gravity and in the room as
opposed to actually winning the debate
per say ox first our debate that this
house believes that investors and
bankers not politicians or social
movements are the best hope for avoiding
climate disaster
and the the side in favor of that motion
is Lisa Ashford chief executive officer
of ethics and Mark campin Allie who
among other things is founder of carbon
tracker those opposing the motion
Matthew Spencer's policy and campaigns
director at Oxfam and that's the
Siddiqui who is visiting professor in
practice at London School of Economics
so which of you two is going to go first
to propose the motion least I would
argue to stand up maybe to speak and
give you a bit more energy at this point
feel free to walk around or whatever and
so you have four minutes starting from
now okay so first let me just say if
we're depending on the politicians to do
absolutely anything then we're going to
find ourselves in a complete predicament
the conservative government has
completely dismantled green policies and
Trump is doing exactly the same thing in
the story I didn't do the show of hands
well I'll point it out
I'm going to stop the clock you have 30
seconds
I'll stop the clock in quickly ask for
shorthand all those in favor of the
motion raise their hands so that the
investors and bankers the best hope all
those against the motion think that
politics I would say it was about 6040
would you accept that as a in favor of
the motion yeah okay so you now have
another three and a half minutes so do
you want to start again either for four
minutes so thirty ok formulas starting
from now all right so first let me start
by saying if we're relying on the
politicians to do anything at the moment
we will end up in a complete predicament
conservative government as completely
dismantled green policies and Trump is
doing the same in the states and this is
a complete disaster in terms of climate
change so in terms of social movements
well they're generally talking about not
doing anything and I would suggest that
in this case it requires real action so
saying divest is a great campaign but
actually we need to be reinvesting as
well as divided by divesting now talking
about money money is one of the most
powerful ways in which you can make
change in the world and your dollar is
actually spending it is one of the most
important ways you can fair trade is is
a movement which has been predominantly
pushed forward by people actually
putting their dollar towards it organic
food and share action is doing a
brilliant job of encouraging people to
as investors to think about taking
action and using their money to make
change when we're talking about this we
need to look at demand and supply and in
terms of the demand we've heard today
that there's quite a lot demand out
there but actually we also heard that
females and Millennials are possibly
some of those with the greatest
potential in moving forward and there's
a huge education gap there so that needs
to be filled if we really want to create
change on the supply side financial
services and not providing the products
that we really need in order to push the
push the
advance the movement in climate change
so there's needs to be a lot more
movement there so when we're thinking
about this we need to think about the
what the WHO and the how the what
financial services are going to provide
the solutions but they need to provide
the products we're talking about current
accounts we're talking about Isis we're
talking about investment products the
who is talking about women and
Millennials who are going to make vast
changes when that income and that
investment is going to come to them in
in years to come and the how do we think
that these people are going to be using
wealth managers and traditional forms of
finance I suggest not I think they're
going to be using apps they're going to
be using their screens to make decisions
they're going to be using artificial
intelligence so yes
banks and the financial institutions do
have the solution but they have to be
completely transformed to provide the
services that we need in order to
provide the solution to climate change
okay thank you very much round of
applause for first speaker okay and I
hand over to the other side laughter
you're going first you have four minutes
starting from now okay thank you so this
is such a non debate in in many ways
feel a bit like get the visual of George
W Bush declaring mission accomplished on
that aircraft carrier so really is it
bankers and private investors that are
more important than social movements and
nonprofits and representatives of the
people I looked at the affiliations of
the of the two members on the on the
side opposite and they're both
nonprofits I wonder why we need them if
the bankers are really more pious than
the Pope we do need the Pope and he is
on our side of the debate but I think
we've got to be careful yet I read about
this company issuing a large green bond
recently just a couple of days ago
a billion dollars of principle market
cap of that company is eight hundred
billion dollars cash that they're
holding two hundred forty nine billion
dollars they're just they're just issued
1 billion dollars in social bonds
because they want to make their supply
chain more environmentally sustainable
specifically they want to invest in this
company that's going to make it easier
for people to extract metals from their
phones so two hundred forty nine days of
the year they're going to build these
phones
that'll make it difficult to extract
metals out of and one day of the year
they're going to invest in this
wonderful fund to make it easy to
extract it out of so let's be careful
here we good is the new cool let's not
fall for tokenism it's quite typical
it's it's like saying that the
shoplifter has agreed not to burgle
between 2:00 p.m. and 5:00 p.m. on a
Monday so let's get rid of the policemen
let's get rid of the after prison
because mission accomplished Enron
environmentalism a green washing as
somebody mentioned earlier on a leading
asset manager said this quite recently
that they're trying to they have a fund
they want to invest in a green fund 25%
of self-styled green investments didn't
meet the bar they were just didn't meet
the standards so we need nonprofits we
need these movements to keep us on the
straight and narrow and to be standard
setters now it's not all bad obviously
there's black rock doing tremendous
amount of work ESG governance and so on
so forth you read their reports and at
the end of all these reports its policy
prescriptions it's like we need parental
action to get us kids to do any work
it's always how do we crowd in private
capital how does public capital crowd in
private capital it's never the other way
around
do you have the board of Berkeley
sitting there saying how are we going to
get are we going to tackle climate
change of anger and crowd in these
social activists and
these politicians it's hard labour in
that direction so look there is a this
generate market failure over here two
types of market failure at least two
types one is that emissions by
definition are externalities and it's
just not possible for agents inside of
the market to do to internalize those
externalities and secondly there's a
coordination failure Sainsbury's will
only act if test goes back first and
Tesco's will act first if the government
has a climate policy policy certainty
framework in there and neither of them
will will work unless Catherine from
share action goes there and makes them
do this so it's absurd to say the test
codes are the heroes and the
protagonists over here I'm going to stop
here and I'll come back hopefully later
on but I'll hand it over to the
apologists now for their argument thank
you so much the the gauntlets been
thrown down you have you have four
minutes starting from from now well last
time I looked is not illegal to burn
fossil fuels the biggest contribution to
climate change and policy makers and
governments and citizens have known
about climate for many years
particularly policymakers going into the
earth summit in 1992 and and yet we know
that 80% of the fossil fuels have to
remain in the ground to stay below two
degrees and based on current emissions
trajectories we're going to be through
this carbon budget within about 30 years
and you're asking us to believe that we
can convince hundreds of governments and
millions of citizens to make tiny
incremental changes even voting that
suddenly will solve this huge problem
and yet when we look at the world of
capital we know that we convert the 30
to 40 bankers and the people who run the
pension schemes and the Norwegian
government sovereign wealth fund we can
take the leadership of the banking
community the heads of the goldman sachs
and our great friends at Morgan Stanley
and JP Morgan and we can say to them
well let's let's change how we how we
think about this it's not illegal to be
a coal company on all the company but
doesn't mean we have to invest in them
it doesn't mean we have to write new
cheque
to expand the fossil fuel economy and is
but obviously it's well known that each
year hundreds of billions go into
subsidizing the fossil fuel economy by
government supported by politicians
supported by citizen voters if I think
oacd
priced out of five hundred billion
dollars a year goes into subsidies
supported by governments and policy
makers and yet when we turn to the
capital markets this year we know in the
last year more money's been deployed and
is being deployed by private capital
into expanding clean energy than into
supporting the fossil fuel economy Trump
has tried to subsidize and benefit the
fossil fuel economy and yet investors
are not writing the checks and this is
because they've begun to reprice the
risk now how had they started to reprice
the risk well if you looked at what
happened in the earth summit it was
business and then there were the NGOs
and then there was science people and
policy makers and governments had their
ears bent by business and when they talk
to business they they often meant well
you know and it meant business all the
bankers and the ambassadors and so the
business world managed to persuade
governments to rein back which is why
Copenhagen was a disaster we wasn't a
great success and so looking at this
moment on profit carbon tracker we said
well let's divide this group called
business because the interest of the
banking community in the fund management
community is not the same as the
interests of business or in the interest
of citizens if we can persuade the
bankers and the pension funds to get on
side with communities and citizens then
we can begin to turn the tide and so in
Paris is here using this idea of
unburnable carbon and stranded assets
the investors go well look why should we
be putting money into supporting the
fossil economy when we can be changing
direction and changing course and so the
bankers arrived in Paris in force and
groups like share action with their
allies amongst the pension funds one
began to change the narrative and we
succeeded to change the story
and then the divestment communities
kicked in why would the divestment be
community be focusing the hundreds of
students be focusing on persuading
pension funds to divest if they didn't
know that money is where the power is
why would even bother each time to come
back and so what they've
done is I persuaded trustees and pension
funds who then have to make their fund
managers at Hermes and L Jim and all the
others to look at reprice in the risk
which is what they began to do and they
stopped repricing they stopped sending
the checks to these countries Coal India
did a tour of Europe to raise new money
in this event in the Indian government's
sale of coal India and the pension fund
said well we're going to say pass to
this because the future isn't going to
be coal is going to be a renewable
energy and my first report handsome
treasurer was tomorrow was actually to
the Bank of England and Mark Carney I
had my hour of fame presenting to the
task force for the Financial Stability
Board that then set up the task force
and climate risk now the regulators are
beginning to change the story with how
financial markets are regulated and if
we look at where the power is that's
where we can get the change Matt you
have four minutes starting from now
Thank You Matthew I'm going to tell you
two stories that illustrate the points
that lofty made about how we made change
happen that has already reduced our
emissions I'm going to take one small
country the UK let's start a mile up the
road a mile up the road at hobart
viaduct was the world's first public
coal-fired power station it was built in
1882 the UK was dependent on coal fire
power power for every day and every year
since that until this year until April
the 21st when we had the first day in
the UK when no coal fire power
electricity was used at all how do we
get to that result it was the result of
two or three different things all of
which and social movements and
governments were central to it started
with the big move against acid rain in
the 1998 1980s where European
governments particularly activist
governments in Scandinavia forced other
European governments just to control Sox
and NOx pollution from those power
stations using regulation it was
followed up by the intervention of
liberal economists and politicians in
the liberalisation of that market which
broke the stranglehold of coal and
introduced gas to the
market it was then followed up with an
enormous effort to get to a formal
phase-out of coal in the UK I was part
of the effort by an development and
environmental NGOs we set to get that
phase-out agreed we sat around the
cabinet table with David Cameron and
persuaded him that he had a de facto
phase-out and that we do know how him in
fact it would be good to announce that
as a formal policy we convinced in not
on the economics not on the investment
case we convinced him on the moral case
and that's why Oxfam who I represent our
have been campaigning for five ten years
on climate change because climate change
is the biggest barrier to ending poverty
in the world there are 13 million people
at this moment in South Sudan Somalia
northern Kenya at extreme risk of
starvation
there they are suffering the three-year
almost three years without rain a super
El Nino which climate change is
exacerbating it so it's the moral case
which is nearly which is invariably
stimulated and championed by social
movements which politics adopts and
investors can then creatively exploit
and the story of coal is social
movements creating a space government
setting the rules and investors then
changing their decisions we are not
investing in the upgrading of those
CalFire power stations anymore because
the rules make it unattractive the
second story is about renewable energy
when I started working in renewable
energy 20 years ago
it provided 2% of the UK's electricity
and there was a period last week
where at providing a 50% of the UK's
electricity and that was driven by
policy in Germany China and the UK
driven by social movements in the first
first and last of those countries and by
government policy in the middle one
we've now got to tackling climate change
is a team sport and we all play
different roles in that the social
movements create the space for political
rules
to be set and policy rules to be set
that investors can exploit
commercialized technology bring down
prices and raise ambition again for
those social movements and for politics
and that's why the motion should not
carry thank you so you guys now have
between you three minutes to respond to
what you've heard and sharpen your
arguments you can split the time between
you if you like or one of you just be
okay you have three minutes starting
from now um
despite what you've said I think the
time has shown that relying on
politicians and governments to create a
stable investment environment is is just
not happening so what's been created is
a huge amount of regulatory risk for
investors and financial institutions so
if we're relying on the government to
set the policy then I just don't feel
that there's enough stability and a long
enough time horizon to best inform those
types of investment decisions so
actually I think it's it's everyday
investors it's the financial
institutions that have to create the
opportunities and go ahead and try and
solve this problem without disregarding
the sort of political agenda
um math your arguments that the rules
that made coal unattractive actually it
was the actions of hundreds of investors
around the world investing in clean
technologies particularly solar that
made it cheaper that has out competed
cold obviously regulation is going to
help but I can't see how if Seoul hadn't
been cheaper what why would it be
deployed and it was the role of
investors and scaling up and
accelerating the deployment of solar
technologies that's helped to be coal
now on the same day that Trump
pulled out at these states from the
Paris agreement was the very same week
that the shareholders and Exxon 62% of
them led by groups like Blackrock and
Vanguard called on essentially on Exxon
to fess up and accept that the game was
up with the fossil fuel industry and it
was the action of the church groups and
groups like share action and others to
persuade the investors that the game was
up on Exxon you can't continue to expand
as an industry that wasn't government
action that was enlightened progressive
investors representing their clients
forcibly arguing the case not just a VAX
on but all the others as well
Shell and BP and the challenges on it
Glencore and others so that's the reason
why we can't wait for governments to
move there's the reason why people are
going to support our side of this
argument is because they can see action
happening with investors while
politicians are still whistling for it
excellent so Mulder
so we rise between you now have three
minutes to respond to Mark's excellent
points and Lisa's excellent points are
starting from let's give it five more
seconds it's time from now so
enlightenment doesn't happen you know
you get a vision and voila from today
I'm enlightened
so clearly there's a there's a
groundswell of social movement that
leads to that point but it's also a case
of enlightened self-interest being a
necessary but not a sufficient condition
I just mentioned the scale in response
to the everyday activity the the bad
impact activity that all of these people
are engaging somebody mentioned how so
much money has been deployed in this
space capital markets in green markets
doubled in the last two years which is
true but more than a third of that is
China that great bastion of free market
leader faire capitalism with no
government intervention at all I know
that Trump's withdrawal from the the
climate agreement it's a coping
mechanism to say that private investors
will take care of it actually the
leadership that's being provided right
now is the governor of California the
mayor of Pittsburgh it's Arnold
Schwarzenegger it's
- you're jamie dimon who stepped up and
said this is what i'm going to be doing
so look I rather rely on the political
forces and governments and Parliament's
then on the vagaries of Elon Musk who
might decide one day to be on the
council and the other day not to be on
the council or where interest rates are
it's a zero interest rate environment
right now everybody's looking at impact
because it's quite cool and the
alternative is negative rates
who knows where rates will be tomorrow
and where you might change so know thank
you very much you still wrote after
that's okay we'll take it at the end I'm
not sure you get that option but anyway
the round of applause for those guys so
you've heard arguments on both sides
anyone want to come in with a question
or argument either way to the panelists
who'd like to jump into this to be over
there we go gentlemen as a microphone
will come to you please say who you are
and who you want to direct your question
at I'm Tristram Stuart feedback and
environmental organization responsible
for having catalyzed of a movement
against food waste there's been a lot of
example giving of how business can help
combat climate change and the energy
transition is the one that is constantly
wheeled out and obviously the energy
transition is precisely the area which
business can solve that particular
problem which is one part of climate
change and climate change is one part of
the environmental disaster no examples
have been given of how business is going
to arrest the rapid demolition of the
world's remaining forests because it's
clear that the only way in which
business can really make big capital out
of it and is doing so increasingly
quickly is by turning the wood into
toilet paper and the land into soy
fields and business is not realistically
within five or 20 years going to tackle
that problem you need government
interaction talk about those
environmental issues that business is
not currently solving rather than the
ones the few examples like energy
transition rate obviously is now the
balls in your court mark and Lisa how do
you reply to that one
for a forester clearly clearly important
and they make up a reasonable proportion
of emissions land-based emissions
land-use change but for me it's the
fossil fuel industry and the burning of
fossil fuels is the one that we can
tackle something alike 40 to 50 percent
of fossil fuels actively trade in the
market at any one time is backed by
private investors and banks and that's
the bit the group that we can deal with
in the case of deforestation obviously
there's companies and consumers that are
involved in consuming palm oil and then
moving on to beef which de forests and
they're still companies involved in that
I think what I'm really calling for is
investors holding companies to account
both have their strategies they deploy
which is why the shareholder resolutions
at Exxon was so important but also
funding the new economy in the energy
transition and that that's that's one
reason why org is so persuasively for
capital
I don't think doesn't sound like you
have an answer to this question because
I don't think he's I don't think is
actually this question is is a do light
read or you don't like revs essentially
what you at the point you're making and
it's it's actually more than whether
read fits I think we heard from quite a
motivational CEO at Danone who talked
about incorporating a social mission
into every element of their organization
and actually as a CEO he was clearly
driven by a number of different factors
and you know his personal bonus was
dependent on a number of factors and I
think having those case studies and
being able to reference those is just
the beginning but then also we talked
very briefly earlier about small
organizations and smees which make up a
huge part of the economy as well and
there are many many social businesses
mission driven businesses who are
tackling social problems or actually
just have a social purpose at the very
heart of the business we will just take
another color don't you've seen oh sorry
criticisms are lovely and Matt would be
good hello it was just a point leading
on if that's okay
just stay here okay how to say go
research her Imperial I'm just touching
upon the point you made and the point
you made about social impact yes a lot
of big companies like dan on like let's
put down on the site let's say Nestle is
focusing on water as one of the SDGs it
makes you wonder why a food company
would want to focus on water you know
you have to kind of think about the
intentionality maybe of course some
businesses are able to tackle some
social elements but why are they doing
it are they doing your question in the
mode so my question is is is the
intentionality of business as good as
the Internet intentionality of
government or NGOs when looking at
actually creating change okay we got
some more comments back there that says
yes someone the white shirt on the back
what a world
yeah hi Rodge words clearly so every
time I think my faith in government
thinks about as low as it can events
prove me to been too optimistic and I
quite support the power of investors
which is really the question on the
other hand I sometimes wonder if
investors would be as motivated as they
are without social movements so I
challenge me question it well let's ask
team Trump first who you're on the side
of the politicians solving this problem
what do you think I would suggest that
our job is not convinced you that
governments always good it's the other
side's job to convince you that
investors and banks are more important
than anybody else in solving this
problem our view is that all of those
actors are important to solving the
problems and we don't have to we
probably agree we need better government
but we have to have social movements
creating this space creating a pressure
for either politicians to get out of bed
to turn the important in to the urgent
or for the market frameworks and
incentives have created whereby
investors can invest safely well
question here Martha would from total
impact capital I put it to you that when
you look at this historically that has
always been the bankers that have driven
the process if you look at the rise of
the church before 1307 it was the
creation of the Templars that created
checkbooks letters of credit the first
multinational corporation if you look at
the rise of the Renaissance it was a
surplus capital that was thrown up by
the creation of the bond market if you
look at why France let loss to the UK it
was because it had an official banking
system if you look at Bretton Woods
Bretton Woods is the dominance of the
American system we've now reached a
critical point in terms of probably the
bankruptcy of that system and it is only
the bankers pricing the externalities
that will create this change exactly the
same as they've done for the last
thousand years
so that love for your a story I raise
you the anti-slavery movement I raise
you the the campaign to get women's
votes I raise you the campaign to get
equal marriage the banks were not
involved in any of those they were in
the slavery weather so that's a Arthur
do you want to come back on that and
then I want to respond to this point
about about on the slavery one it was
the inability of the slave traders to
get insurance on their boats that was
one of the kid that killed that was one
of the things that killed the slave
trade let's be correct about the history
it was the politicians debated the
politicians debated anti-slavery for
hundreds of years as you well know was
actually the insurance industry that
decided not to insure boats that
couldn't go outside the waters of the
carrying slaves that ended in the slave
industry let's be correct on that one
yeah another point here just a quick
reminder I think the best chance of
avoiding a planetary car crash is by
following the cop process and the cop
process was entirely government policy
local volunteerism local action yep your
beloved Paris really wins decide wins
this side the argument mark or not
well the volunteerism well put the
politicians did they did the cop21 yeah
my point was was that when the
politicians saw clearly that the the
financial sector was coming in behind a
climate deal and it was groups of big
institutional investors
forcibly turning up and saying look you
know Bob Dylan was right money doesn't
just talk it shouts and it's very good
at speaking to the politicians and
finally the politicians had some wiggle
room they were saying well listen if the
investors at the end of the day only or
companies wants a deal who are you as a
mere management member of other company
to go against what your shareholders are
saying and that's one of the reasons why
you know the why we had a successful
Paris agreement and sense of everyone
agreeing together one way forward any
more comments the women have been quite
quiet during this debate we got here we
are done that around the mics coming to
here to say hey it's Matt my name is
Matt I'm I'm from the EBRD European bank
so it's a government funded institution
the question is is it really possible to
differentiate between banks and
politicians any longer and media in any
event so is this debate completely false
in what so just elaborate a bit more
well you know hold on just were there
well man that that's one part perhaps
but the other thing is you know it's
just so interchangeable you know today
you're the politician next day you are
be you know whatever golden slacks on is
just completely interchangeable so you
know we think we're voting for the
politicians we think we're voting for
social policies change what not
ultimately is the capital that is
defining that so it's there's a
revolving door so to speak and then
basically it's hand in glove and you
know both sides of the debate are its
again force both sides the finance
industrial complex means the debate is
irrelevant
well I cleared and think some
particularly here in the UK climate
change is not a political debate anymore
it's a resolved issue we have the best
policy framework for companies to
operate in and I would suppose that it's
a result of the political process
the lobbying process social movement
which is behind the fact that it is a
settled issue I think the the dilemma
always is like finance is a tremendous
force can be a force for good as a
tremendous force its resources that are
required there's no question about the
scale of resources required you've got
to get mainstream fine
into it so it's an ecosystem we need
everybody but if you're going to say
that in the sequencing of it
it's private investors and banks that
are more important then I'm afraid it's
it's just not true it's a no contest
you know cavalry needs horses but you
don't lead the horses with other horses
you need Wonder Woman and other generals
to lead the charge and that's the case
over here we'll still need to deploy
capital but you just can't rely on the
captains of capital do that leading for
you our time is Pratt almost up so you
each now have two minutes closing
remarks to finally swing the audience
your way so those in favor of the motion
get to go first you have two minutes
between you two some items are all you
buy why you should I would love to think
that governments will run as fast as
they can to get the change that we need
in the limited time that we've got and
my firm view is that we can mobilize the
owners of capital to address the climate
challenge before we can mobilize
governments to do that due to inertia an
invested interest over government and
the alliances that we've seen built
particularly around the shareholder
resolution against Exxon and Sheldon BP
and the others which are now in the
majority showed us how quickly you can
build alliances whilst people in the
political process of faffing around so I
think that where we need to get to is
the fossil fuel industry to essentially
agree to one itself down governments are
not going to ask for that consumers may
that they may have the whistle whereas
the owners of those companies can get
companies to begin to put in place those
two degree business plans which is what
we're beginning to see being published
now by companies like to Thailand the
others is to align their businesses and
it's not the pressure is not coming from
governments the pressure is coming from
the shareholders then marvelously this
new group of these financial regulators
and the accountants and what I'm arguing
which is why you should support my our
case is that it's our ability to move
quickly and with force of action that
shows how quickly how the approach of
private capital can win before
governments have even got out of bed or
even government's change and you happen
to deal with a whole new group in Fatt
we've got a new climate minister
today you know how can we handle that
when we've got institutional investors
that will be in place year in and year
out essentially changing the course of
direction for companies and Hermes
published a great essay today on their
website about the role of institutional
investors around climate go away and
read it because we've got lessons to
learn there which is why I think you
should support our side of the debate in
this resolution you guys have two
minutes starting from now so listening
to one of the panel's earlier and I was
wondering why is that that goldman sachs
didn't come up with the social finance
bond they have the expertise they have
the ability to do it you needed a
separately created entity to to come up
with that or the other panel that had
multiple global heads of responsibility
as the titles on the panel now is
thinking if every if that's the title
does that mean every other departmental
head in those organizations or global
heads of irresponsibility I think that
is the implication that you've got this
sort of clean bit over here and
everything else is dirty look if you
just if you have to think about how do
executive committees and boards work
within these companies you need a lot of
external pressure just to get buy-in
within the executive team within the
board to get action on some of these and
that pressure comes from social
movements from government from
regulations and so on and so forth and
so we help the intrapreneurs by being
pacesetters and accelerants from the
outside through the social movement and
as i've said before just because the
Porcher promises to stop poaching for a
day you don't make him the gamekeeper
thank you
we're still out of everyone
well I mean I think I think the the
other side I've had a very difficult job
of convincing you that finance on its
own we'll do everything we need to be
done and there as I say change is a team
sport social movements need you the
investors to deliver into the space that
can be created and I think we'd agree we
all need better government great thank
you very much so a round of applause to
both sides some good cutting for us
there
so I want to see a show of hands those
of you who are in favor of the motion
that bankers and investors are the best
hope to avert a climate crisis let's see
your hands today and those who are
against the motion I think that this
side has managed to move some opinion
across so so the faffing about Trump
side as one and the the bankers have
been the accountants of loss were a good
good effort on all sides thank you very
much and now for our final key note to
end the day I hand over to Andrew and
Prince max
you